[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le débrief
des questions au gouvernement de ce
mardi 7 avril s'est une nouvelle fois
l'épidémie de coronavirus et ses
conséquences sur notre vie qui a occupé
la quasi totalité des débats dans
l'hémicycle avec une interrogation porté
par plusieurs députés sur la doctrine
française autour des masques de
protection
faut-il ou non généralisée leur usage on
écoute
arnaud viala députés les républicains
alors que l'académie de médecine vient
de préconiser le port généralisé de
masque pendant la période de confinement
et lors de sa levée
votre gouvernement se voit contraint
d'opérer une spectaculaire volte face
sur sa doctrine précisément concernant
les masques jusqu'à la semaine dernière
vous juger le port du masque
je cite inutile voire contre-productif
pour les personnes non infectées
désormais vous encourager le grand
public à porter des masques alternatifs
les masques chirurgicaux et en réserve
et c'est bien normal au personnel
soignant
ce revirement nous interroge d'abord il
n'y a aucune décision de recommandations
de port du masque ni obligatoire ni
recommandé en tout cas à ce stade pour
la population générale
nous en restons à l'heure à laquelle je
vous parle à la stratégie qui est 2
permettre de protéger les soignants vous
l'avez dit vous-même par des masques
ffp2 ou des masques chirurgicaux les
soignants mais également les patients
les plus fragiles les personnes les plus
fragiles ou les personnes qui présentent
des risques particuliers à l'heure
actuelle je ne peux que confirmer ce
qu'a dit la porte-parole du gouvernement
à savoir que les gestes barrière la
distanciation sociale le lavage des
mains le fait de tousser dans son coude
sont les mesures reconnues par l' oms
comme les plus efficaces
mais s'il s'avère que le port d'un
masque en population générale pouvait
permettre de renforcer l'efficacité du
dispositif si les recommandations des
scientifiques allaient dans ce sens
alors nous serions amenés à communiquer
en ce sens mais à ce stade je ne mendie
la doctrine n'a pas évolué autre thème
clé quel avenir pour l'hôpital public le
député communiste stéphane peu s'est
inquiété de l' annonce de suppressions
de lits à l'hôpital de nancy l'occasion
d'une mise au point du ministre de la
santé
chacun mesure combien notre système
public de santé est un bien commun
il nous faut préserver renforcé pour
répondre aux défis de l'avenir
dans ce contexte nous sommes
profondément choqués par les propos
tenus ce week-end par le directeur de la
rs du grand est confirmant en pleine
crise sanitaire
la suppression de 581 18 emplois et 274
lits à l'hôpital de nancy
cette crise révèle qu encore plus
l'exigence d'abandonner les orientations
de ces trente dernières années
conduisant aux suppressions d'emplois et
aux suppressions de lits je crois que
l'état d'esprit
s'agissant dernière de l'hôpital et
notamment s'agissant de l'hôpital de
nancy nous sommes pas loin de partager
j'ai immédiatement dit publiquement que
tous les plans de réorganisation de
restructurer de restructuration de
réduction de lee était suspendu leurs
ailes et à la mobilisation de tous elle
est à la mobilisation avec les soignants
qui sauvent des vies et je crois que
dans le jour d'après cette crise
sanitaire
nous aurons à repenser jeu reprend les
mots du président de la république qu'il
a prononcé à mulhouse le 23 mars dernier
nous aurons à repenser notre modèle
sanitaire notre modèle hospitalier pour
tenir compte de ce que cette crise
sanitaire nous enseigne avec ce cas-là
d'incroyablement réussi pour l'hôpital
comme cette augmentation du nombre de
lits de réanimation
comme cette mobilisation sans faille
comme cette capacité de réaction qui
fait que par tour le pic est très élevé
nous faisons face et nos soignants font
face avec bravoure et courage et tenir
aussi compte des tensions et des
implications sur l'organisation du parc
hospitalier sur les plans d'organisation
de financement tous et toutes ces
questions fondamentales ainsi que sur
les carrières
comment y voir plus clair sur la
stratégie française de sortie du
confinement c'est le député liberté et
territoires paul molac qui a posé la
question dans l'hémicycle et c'est le
premier ministre edouard philippe qui
lui a répondu en personne
sa seule intervention du jour vos propos
sur le déconfinement ont inquiété de
nombreux français parce que mal préparé
mal anticipé il se des confirmands
pourrait provoquer une nouvelle flambée
de contamination et son lot de décès la
situation actuelle en chine d'ailleurs
n'est pas pour nous rassurer
or quelle que soit la stratégie qui sera
décidé cela ne pourra se faire sans
véritables moyens pour surveiller l'état
immunitaire de la population et éviter
la
la contagion on a des tests sérologiques
fiable monsieur le ministre viennent
nous le dire c'est une bonne nouvelle
alors moi aussi je réitère quand est ce
qu'on sera en mesure finalement de
tester la population est ce que ce sera
fin avril
fin mai parce qu'évidemment et on ne
pourra pas lutter contre le virus hand
et confinant si on n'a pas les moyens
pour le faire vous évoquez la question
de demain ou en vérité d'ailleurs même
plus tôt d'après demain c'est à dire ce
qui se passera lorsque nous serons prêts
à procéder à ce déconfinement dans
certains parlent donc personnellement je
parle peu je réponds aux questions qu'on
pose mais je parle peu pourquoi parce
que nous sommes en train d'y travailler
ce n'est pas pour demain aujourd'hui
l'impératif c'est de faire en sorte que
le confinement fonctionne et lors du
confinement va durer et c'est tout à
fait difficile à supporter pour beaucoup
de français j'en ai parfaitement
conscience mais c'est indispensable si
nous ne voulons pas nous retrouver dans
une situation qui serait pire encore que
celle que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup de questions qui sont
liées aux déconfinement demain ou
après-demain beaucoup elles sont
compliquées parce que pour beaucoup
d'entre elles elles tiennent à des
éléments dont nous ne disposons pas
encore à des réponses dont nous ne
disposons pas encore
que faire pour maintenir le lien avec
les élèves pendant le confinement selon
jean michel blanquer entre 5 et 8%
d'entre eux ont été perdus depuis la
fermeture des classes comment améliorer
le suivi
c'est la question qu'a posée béatrice
descamps député udi au ministre de
l'éducation nationale
malgré l'amélioration de l'enseignement
à distance
l'égalité entre les élèves est remise en
cause
de par les différences d'accès à
internet le manque de matériel
informatique dans les écoles dans l'est
à la maison la possibilité des familles
d'aider leurs enfants ou bien d'autres
phrases encore aussi je voudrais vous
interrogez monsieur le ministre ce
manque qu'il y aura forcément dans les
apprentissages coraux nos jeunes de tous
niveaux et en satiné et cette inégalité
qui va s'accroître encore comment ces
élèves vont ils pouvoir être aidées
alors il ya ce que nous faisons pendant
la crise et ce que nous ferons après la
crise pendant la crise nous allons
chercher les élèves c'est tout le
quadrillage que nous faisons et auquel
je faisais référence avec les chefs
d'établissements en particulier et ceci
nous permet de diminuer jour après jour
le nombre d'élèves qui ne sont pas
inclus dans la continuité pédagogique
il en reste encore mais nous réussissons
ça là aussi parce que nous sommes un
grand service public de l'éducation
nationale ensuite des moyens spécifiques
du matériel informatique prêter grâce
aux collectivités locales souvent et au
monde associatif avec lesquels nous
sommes la main dans la main et puis il y
a aussi des dispositifs particuliers
avec la poste qui doit qui va nous
permettre à partir de cette semaine
d'envoyer des documents rédigés par les
professeurs par la poste avec une
enveloppe comme étant un renvoi gratuit
ensuite par la famille aux élèves que
nous n'arrivons pas à atteindre par un
par internet
voilà pour le débrief des questions au
gouvernement de ce mardi 7 avril une
séance une nouvelle fois presque
exclusivement consacré aux conséquences
de l'épidémie de coronavirus la semaine
prochaine pas de vacances parlementaires
les députés siègeront
quant à nous on se retrouve pour un
nouveau débrief